in the last video i started to talk
about the formula for curvature and just
to remind everyone where we are
you imagine that you have some kind of
curve in let's say two-dimensional space
just for the sake of being simple and
let's say this curve is parameterized by
a function s of t so every number t
corresponds to some point on the curve
for the curvature you start thinking
about unit tangent vectors at every
given point what does the unit tangent
vector look like
and the curvature itself which is
denoted by this sort of greek letter
kappa
is going to be the rate of change of
those unit vectors kind of how quickly
they're they're turning in direction not
with respect to the parameter t but with
respect to arc length d s
and so what i mean by arc length here
is just a tiny step you could think the
size of a tiny step along the curve
would be ds and you're wondering as you
take a tiny step like that does the unit
tangent vector turn a lot or does it
turn a little bit and the little
schematic that i said you might have in
mind is just a completely separate space
where for each one of these unit tangent
vectors you go ahead and put them in
that space
saying okay so this one would look
something like this this one is pointed
down and to the right so it would look
very much down
and you're wondering basically as you
take tiny little steps of size ds
what does this
change
to the unit tangent vector and that
change you know it's going to be it's
going to be some kind of vector
and because the curvature is really just
a value a number that we want all we
care about is the size of that vector
the size
of the change to the tangent vector
as you take a tiny step in d s now this
is pretty abstract right i've got these
two completely separate things that are
not the original function that you have
to think about um
you have to think about this unit
tangent vector function and then you
also have to think about this this
notion of arc length and the reason by
the way that i'm using an s here as well
as here for the
for the parametrization of the curve is
because they're actually quite related
and i'll get to that a little bit below
and to make it clear what this means i'm
going to go ahead and go through an
example here where let's say our
parametrization
with respect to t
is
a cosine sine pair so we've got cosine
of t is the x component and then sine of
t is the y component
sine of t and just to make it so that
it's not completely boring let's let's
multiply both of these components by a
constant r
and what this means you might recognize
this cosine sine pair what this means
is that in the xy plane you're actually
drawing a circle with radius r so this
would be some kind of circle
with a radius r
and while i go through this example i
also want to make a note of what things
would look like a little bit more
abstractly if we just had you know s of
t equals not specific functions that i
lay down but just any general function
for the x component and for the y
component and the reason i want to do
this is because
the concrete version is going to be
helpful and simple and something we can
deal with but almost so simple as to not
be indicative of just how complicated
the normal circumstance is but the the
more general circumstance is so
complicated i think it'll actually
confuse things a little bit too much so
it'll be it'll be good to kind of go
through both of them in parallel
and
the first step is to figure out what is
this unit tangent vector what is that
function that at every given point gives
you a unit tangent vector to the curve
and the first thing
for that is to realize that we already
have a notion of what should give the
tangent vector the derivative
of our vector valued function as a
function of t
the direction in which it points is in
the tangent direction so if i go over
here and if i compute this derivative
and i say
s prime of t
which involves just taking the
derivative of both components so the
derivative the derivative of cosine
is negative sine
of t
multiplied by r and the derivative of
sine is cosine
of t
multiplied by r
and more abstractly this is just going
to be
anytime you have two different component
functions
you just take the derivative of each one
and and hopefully you've seen this if
not maybe take a look at the videos on
taking the derivative of a precision
vector-valued function
and this this we can interpret as that
tangent vector but it might not be a
unit vector right we want a unit tangent
vector and this this only promises us
the direction so what we do to normalize
it
what we do to normalize it
and get a
unit tangent vector function maybe a
different color
and get a unit vector tangent function
which i'll call capital t of lowercase t
that's kind of confusing right capital t
is for tangent vector lowercase t is the
parameter
so i'll try to keep that straight it's
sort of standard notation but
it there is the potential to confuse
with this
what that's going to be
is your vector value derivative
your vector value derivative but
normalized so we have to divide by
whatever its magnitude is as a function
of t
and in this case in our specific example
that magnitude
if we take the magnitude of
negative sine of tr
multiply by r and then cosine of t
cosine of t multiplied by r
so we're taking the magnitude of this
whole vector what we get
making myself even more room here
is the square root
of sine squared negative sine squared is
just going to be sine squared
so sine squared of t
multiplied by r squared and then over
here cosine squared times r squared
cosine squared of t
times r squared
we can bring that r squared outside of
the radical to sort of factor it out
turning it turning it into an r and on
the inside
we have sine squared plus cosine squared
i'm being too lazy to write down the t's
right now because no matter what the t
is that whole value just equals 1.
so
this entire thing is just going to equal
r
and what that means is that our unit
tangent vector up here
is going to be the original function but
divided by r it happens to be a constant
usually it's not but it happens to be a
constant in this case so what that looks
like
given that our original function is
negative sine of t times r and cosine of
t times r we're dividing out by an r the
ultimate function that we get
is just negative sine of t
and then cosine of t
and for fear of running a little bit
along i think i'll colored it into this
video and continue on with the same
argument in the next video